[Music]
Anna thank you so much for joining me
here today can you tell me a little bit
about your chess upbringing uh like I
think when I was like 15 I was really
spending a lot of time studied alone we
didn't have computers back in my time
and I remember sitting in my room and it
was about like 30 different books in
forat around me I was writing down I
still have this notes and uh it's hard
to say maybe like all my free time
around this year and after moving to
United States I remember I studyed chess
for six hours plus 1 hour sports but
it's also it's been a while since last
time I was so serious about my chest
preparation now sometimes I really have
such days where I study a lot but not
every day of course now you become a mom
too so you know it's it's yes when you
have yeah when you have two kids like
something something happens
unfortunately too often but did you have
a book that um kind of influenced your
your chess as you grow as you grew up uh
I don't have such books and such book
maybe vit's books had like good
influence on me and um the very old my
system nich book I don't know you
remember probably this this book and
vit's books we didn't have many books it
was back in um Ukraine it was Soviet
Union it was some deficit it was hard to
get good books there I remember from my
parents too when when I was growing up
they they had the informat inators as
you're mentioning and you had to write
down the games and sometimes you had to
pass them from player to player do you
have to do something like that yes I
remember when I played in 2000 for
Ukraine I played chess Olympia and last
day like everyone was having fun and I
remember I took some new in chess or in
for months and I was writing down my
lines instead of going out and Hing with
other players and then you had to
memorize them yes memorize and this is
so interesting just to see all these
notes I still have them yes maybe
someday I will put on Facebook and
that's what we did it's a lot of time to
write everything down from this informat
on newest and I knew I had to do it now
because I didn't have it's it was not
mine it was borrowed from someone and
you have to be organized did you have
were you writing them with different
colors and making sure that yeah this is
true and I remember I I was so like
buying like special organized in Germany
I was so happy because I couldn't buy
this in Ukraine I had my way to organize
it and usually it goes by index by
infont index and you put like this
papers in the right in the right place I
remember that I feel that people these
days don't use the echo code anymore
they just know the names of the openings
if you tell them the echo yeah you can
make search by position right in your
notes if you want it's much easier these
days you mentioned that you were
spending um time uh with all of these
books and stuff and I know you're also
passionate about solving puzzles yes
this is also I wanted I wanted to say I
saw I have some my favorite book it's
old one this is just it begins with like
two pieces versus two pieces I think
it's with Vladimir of who was uh but it
was not his puzzles I like this book I
like some I don't like very artificial
when you have like Checkmate in 57 or
you have like very unrealistic position
but I really I enjoy it do you still do
that these days to train yes I do it I
do it I have this book and I sold it uh
maybe three times but you don't remember
all solution and after like maybe 10
years I I'm like starting from the
beginning yeah and you're one of the
players Onna that also has done
blindfold Simons one of the female
players that that did this uh how do you
train for something like that uh this is
also like I didn't do it for a while and
I want I want to try because I'm not so
sure sure if I can do it again U my
record was 10 bards but here in St Louis
I I think I played seven or eight and I
played versus Rex it was tough and
toughest game and I I still remember
opening it was cilian with G3 and he had
very good
position yes I played and I trained as
as a child and when we were with my
father was on public transportation I
remember promoting porn
blind this was the beginning and then I
played uh simos as a like when I was 16
years old 18 years old in the club I
played for like four boards but against
really strong people it was 22 I still
remember score and I remember who played
yeah so this was from childhood I always
enjoy and we analyzed a lot with my
father he's a strong chess player like
2300 in his best years maybe even more
and we like discuss a lot of like
positions somewhere without chess very
nice and I wanted to ask you as well
Anna uh you just won recently the Karen
cup which was amazing it was wonderful
seeing you win the competition although
you started rating wise as one of the
lower players um how are you have you
prepared for this specific
tournament
emotionally emotionally yes I I visit my
friends like sagalchik family Olga Sagal
and uh uh in New York it's my
preparations I'm
good good some inact influence good mood
and uh yes like trying to do like the
same routine establish the same routine
which I had during the K cup and yes
like trying to train do some calculation
skills and this is about it know like
special secrets well thank you Anna even
if they were you will tell us later yes
yeah thank you so much for joining me
today I wish you good luck thanks so
[Music]
much